okay hey what's going on it's Bill Burr
and it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday Morning
podcast and I'm just checking in on you
and I know where does my skin end where
does the Malibu sweatshirt sweatshirt
begin you know I was trying to be I was
trying to be soft and cuddly today it
just didn't I swear to God it's not this
light but I'm looking at myself on the
screen I look [__] horrible this
looks like a uh like a a hospital sheet
anyway that's a rich guy
sweatshirt is it yeah that's like you
never no one's working out in that
sweatshirt
that's that you go by camera you go by
uh picture frames and that's s funny
about this joke I was out in Malibu I
was out in Malibu staying in a
trailer doing mushrooms and we went down
and I just it's just it's a touristy
thing but it's one of those things that
if you go there you got to get it and
you know what I'm not going to lie to
you I [__] love this thing and I also
love that it says Malibu and then people
look at me and just think that I'm I'm
going to like Lululemon and [__] there's
just something funny about that to me
you know Joe I figured it'd be a perfect
balance with with your George C Scott
[__] uh you know old school Lee
Marvin Vibes you know same free actors I
always bring up Joe bartnik is here
because not only is he a great friend of
mine Joey B put out a killer special and
now we got tour dates coming all of a
sudden look look who's look who's
selling tickets remember Look Who's
Talking now Look Who's Talking Too look
who's Look Who's Talking Now it's a dog
I'm a dog talking
yeah so Joe bartnik all right if you
like your
comedy the way you like your [__]
sandwiches all red meat
[__] none of that beta lettuce on it you
want to go see Joe bartnik uh 29th and
31st New Year's Eve boa ratton that's a
rich person right oh yeah it's fantastic
and I love bokeh bokeh Sandman uh sadman
comedy Cafe sadman yeah sadman comedy
Cafe in BOGO Ron look it's funny because
he is Arab so he is a sandman oh there
you go all right so but he's called
sadman sadman all right you're goingon
to be a little Tango and cash down there
uh January 11th you're going to be at
the Funny Bone in
Columbus uh Dave Stroop these are all
the old all my old stomping grounds
Vinnie Brand New Brunswick Stress
Factory on uh January 14th and I don't
know where this one is on uh Ben Salem
Parks Casino in outside of Philly right
there oh right outside of Philly so
there you go look at that we got Florida
we got Ohio where all the great coaches
come from you got uh you got Vinnie BRS
New Jersey where all the all the [__]
Tony uh what's his name Terry cutlets
yeah uh that's not his name what's the
guy's name on the is it Deo right no Deo
is an actual what's his first name is it
Tony this can't be Tony that's two on
the notes I think it is Tony it is Tony
Tony DeVito right oh Tony deito right I
think so I don't I know who you're
talking about hey man I don't know what
I don't know what's going on all right
I'm just trying to get the Steelers over
it was easy a month ago they're going to
get nine wins now it's like oh my God
thank God my kid got a scholarship in
college well what happened they lost to
two two and 10 teams yeah in five days
us yeah congratulations I heard you know
what dude we [__] own you guys the
way the Giants own the Patriots like we
can't beat the [__] Giants I don't
give a [__] if they're one in 15 or 15-
one the pre-season the season the Super
Bowl we just don't beat the B Che is
just a great coach he's just a great
coach you know I don't like his coaching
tree that's the latest thing it's like
Nick Sabin in there Nick Sabin in the
bich coaching tree the [__] Cleveland
Browns fired bill bich with Nick Sabin
underneath him in like [__]
1995 thank God that's what they did yeah
yeah thank God that's what they you know
it's that's what Cleveland does they
just they they're the mistake by the
lake and they want to stay that way
although they're playing pretty good
football this year huh they're all right
right uh they beat us I believe okay
them's fighting words so I didn't want
to I don't want to compliment Cleveland
no no it's fine I I always have a good
time in Cleveland yeah I have a good
time everywh let's be honest you have a
good time everywhere I have a good time
everywhere I enjoy everywhere I
go long as the bar was a war zone and
had a great time dude when we went to
Israel there was some [__] going
down in Jerusalem is the best yeah and
the guys the guy goes to us he goes oh
yeah you know sorry about that stuff
going on down Jerusalem and you said
yeah I don't care about the Jesus stuff
let's just let's just go to they kept
trying to drag me off the beach we're
literally looking I I talk about this in
my ACT I'm not trying to do we're
looking at beautiful women look like
Wonder Woman they're awesome they
they're beautiful they can kill you you
want to [__] them they're hey you want
to go see some 3,000 year old [__] you
read about in Catholic school for a
decade like no no I want to smoke sticks
and drink and have a good time
with they need to get rid of all of that
[__] they should just move it like to
Disney
World I'm surprised I'm which person
hasn't just bought it you know what they
need to do they need to make a Wailing
Wall for [__] Sports gamblers on for
like Sunday
evening guy he hit the [__] upright
just and then you stuff your money that
you owe the bookie into the [__] wall
is that what the Wailing Wall is people
complain dude I don't know
no it's you go I don't know what it is
you go there and you start [__]
crying and then you stick a piece of
paper in there and everybody's praying
to God but God likes your people more
than he likes these other people but he
has made everybody and God loves every
none of it makes any sense you stick
money in the wall it's a bunch of no you
stick like [__] like notes like
you're talking to some chicken class you
stick them in there you stick them
please please get two more wins
Pittsburgh yeah yeah I can't do it you
know from the Steel Curtain to this I
mean if you wanted to you could bother
him with that [__] but wouldn't that
make life easier if like Jeff basos or
someone just bought all the religious
[__] and moved it somewhere like
wherever we can get to easy direct
flights have a Spirit flight to theiling
wall what if it just went away like a
fad it it was like a [__] 5,000 year
fad and it just went away like the Twist
and nobody
yeah oh that Christianity [__] yeah
that's so F yeah that went away what
were we thinking yeah what were we
thinking dancing with people moving
their hips guy walking on water what are
you doing it was silly that was stupid
yeah no one's and a lot of people died
that was stupid kids got raped what were
we thinking they said the guy like came
back from the dead how stupid was that
and people believed it people believed
it yeah enough people believed it dude
you know what me one time I [__]
worked with this guy and the guy was
burning the light he was pissing me off
but his closing bit was [__] amazing
he was doing Howard coel doing the
resurrection of of Jesus Christ which is
basically I almost remember that from I
probably told you about it and he was
doing the low thing here we are standing
out here the Son of God is just BL never
say wait a minute what is this what is
this he's like the rock is rolling back
and here comes Jesus Christ clearly
risen from the dead clearly oh my God
this reporter has seen it all I'll never
it was [__] amazing down goes Jesus
down goes Jesus dude it was [__] it
was my favorite thing cuz he did a dead
on one but he was like burning the light
like you couldn't believe he got to like
then started the bit no like I told him
hey man you know you're supposed to only
do [__] 25 you you did like 40 and oh
yeah sorry dude the next night he did 50
50 and then he act oh yeah I was this
this is like 30 years ago one of my
first headline dates working up in uh I
think I was in Vermont was a Roger Paul
gig I would even way way back in the day
I it's like there's nothing better than
featuring nothing easier you do your 20
minutes you hang out you you have some
drinks you can drink at the beginning
thech
yeah it's perfect who wants to go long
featuring like you're a [__] you don't
have to wait till the headliner done to
out to [__] do the outro remember
that [__] oh yeah hosting is like you
sit there and sit there and sit there
when you're featuring you're already at
the you're already down the street yeah
for you uh civilian out there when you
host you go up you warm up you know you
get them going you got to take the
[__] beach and then you bring up the
[__] Feature Feature ends you outro
him you do another couple minutes then
you bring up the headliner then you had
to sit there for 45 to an hour let that
guy finish and then you had to go up all
right that's one more time that's it
thanks for coming out BL you literally
had to hang out for like another [__]
hour just to do that when you're
starting out you know you had like the
day job and all of that oh dude it and
you knew his act by Thursday oh yeah but
you had listen to it four more times
I'll tell you what kills me is how long
45 minutes seemed to me when I started
out now 45 minutes goes by in like a
second but just to have to sit there I
guess if I have to sit there and wait
for someone else to do 45 minutes before
I go on I had a great education working
the door at the punchline when it was
you Jo I would never know that about
you I had the education out on the
street I got my education punch the door
at the punch line there's two ways to
work with that is when I sit and listen
to you and itel and Louis CK and
Chappelle I get to it soak it all in
that was amazing but we talking about
educations you know I get free college
sweatshirts and swag everywhere we go I
go Jo you're a m guy yeah so every if I
have any like whatever I'll say Rhode
Island I'll say Syracuse I'll say uh
UCLA whatever people like ah did you go
there when I wear duke or Michigan no
one ever says did you go
there no what year to graduate do no oh
you you went to an arbor no never that's
awesome that would probably happen to me
like I remember when I used to do the
road with like verzy and we would go to
like I remember one time we were
somewhere in South Carolina this just
this [__] I think it was Charleston
this picturesque like really it was just
ridiculous like like an old school like
like TV show would be shot there or
something it was just the most beautiful
place ever and we were just walking
around like sweatpants and FY has his
Yankee hat on people were just looking
at us like we were like in the witness
protection program like going look at
these two [__] Meatheads what are
they doing here I'm like that everywhere
and I it makes me it makes me get helped
cuz it's like any any town I'm in people
like at the CBS like do you need help
sir cuz like why is this guy here like I
I stand out every me and verie
especially stand we' be drinking in
public like leaning up against the
Gazebo like smoking sticks and people
were walking by just looking going like
are those bookies like I mean I I you
know what it really is it was really
verzy it wasn't me like I I look like a
cop but when I hang out with verie then
immediately I look like a crooked cop
right I look like I'm making a drop or
something well yeah you're you're giving
uh you're saying who's testifying
against verie yeah you're like hey
here's who I saw going to the courthouse
yeah verie looks like a rat or I look
like a crook speaking of ver
uh he's going to be at the gry gramar
theater in New Year New Year's Eve I
promised him I would give a shout out
for that take so happy for him that's so
ver love ver look at both you guys
here's my coaching tree huh Paul verie
and [__] now Joe bartnik going around
the country selling out so some good
seats recently hope it keep thank you
and hope it keeps going talking about
did you just see that right there this
is what like truly funny people are like
they're [__] humble they suck at the
BS now you know I it's going pretty good
if you were a [__] hack you wouldn't
be on this show you you you would you
would figur out the Matrix of uh social
billion views on doing whatever oh yeah
you'd have some little little thing that
you do and then that sell I mean I'm not
you know saying that hack shouldn't sell
tickets no everyone should everyone
should sell it rises up the more I mean
this is like the boom everyone's doing
Arenas now not everyone like you it's
not it's not just you and like Rogan
there's like 20 people do it's crazy how
many people are buying tickets to see
comedy and is it because like everything
else is just so muted and just like oh
it's terrible that now comedy's risen up
so high I don't I mean literally it's
like booming yeah I am I don't know I
don't want to jinx anything but uh but
talk well I think it it it fits now
where you can
consume everything immediately like you
can just watch a whole season just
[__] shotgun it and I think by the
the nature of the fact that like jokes
you hear at once and then you're done
with it it it it just causes us we're
working at a pace that fits with the way
people are consuming media right now
where it's just like you know they watch
a movie they're done with the movie they
watch a series they're done with the
series they move on you as a comedian
though you just keep coming up with new
jokes and new jokes as long as you keep
making them laugh who doesn't want to
laugh and like that's one of the main
things I look at when I'm on my phone is
I just look at [__] that's going to
either blow my mind or make me laugh one
of the other so I watch a lot of sports
and a lot of I don't know people just
yeah imitating people or something my
feet is like the Rolling
Stones Sports and it just always yeah
it's just fun stuff uh yeah but you
actually read a lot you do read a lot
you're very
quietly a a big you wouldn't know it Joe
to look at you I I do would I like to I
I owe you this book I'm halfway through
but the beginning of the NFL it's just
great stuff yeah I mean
I
dude I just set you up I set you up like
you're out here reading the classics you
know like Joe's out here reading about
physics or something you just go I did
read something Rec there's no pictures
bring it to you it's about the beginning
of the NFL it is amazing oh is this
where they talk about like half those
guys were bookies and G oh yeah
absolutely they're they're meeting in
the back of gas stations and stuff like
that you know it's it's the good stuff
it's the real it's the NFL they've kind
of been fixing it since the beginning uh
well yes yes like I don't know like how
could you f there's so many [__]
people involved and everybody looks like
they're trying yeah just a little shave
here and there like boxing you could
always tell like when somebody threw a
fight as a boxer because you just see
like the the punch wasn't there or just
you know they barely got hit and they
fall down they miss but like with
football with all the [__] that goes
on I mean maybe it's it's like the
officiating I will say one of my big
conspiracy theories um one of my big
ones Joe you have several no like when I
go to give my my talks okay
yeah in a conference room at a hotel uh
one of my big one is I just don't
understand how with all of this [__]
technology the [__] they can never
get a camera right on the goal line it's
always a little this way or it's a
little hey by that angle you can't quite
tell put it on the [__] goal line put
one right above it what is the [__]
problem or first down it's always this
way well you know because it gives them
the [__] leeway or how about a chip
that just one the crosses is that it
goes off and that's
it I you know you I mean there there's
plenty of solutions but I think it it
gives up it gives up
control yeah they always want to have an
out yes they want to have like oh well
here I mean the thing and we're going to
complain about this and what are we
going to do next Sunday we're going to
sit right down and watch it you know
what though I will say this I watch less
and less and less because the product
stinks unless you have one of the five
or six great quarterbacks great okay
quarterbacks it's just watching Bad
football right that's why I Love College
because in college you don't have to
have Joe Montana you don't have to you
know you don't you don't have to have
the best of the best because most teams
run the ball and most teams can throw
like 10 yards down field it's kind of
like more like the football I grew up on
you know where like you're a big colle
every I used to not be up like the NFL's
great college now it's like college is
so much better to me especially the SEC
and like Michigan that's why Bama I mean
I got Michigan is gonna be sick I got to
tell you though like I mean that that
Thanksgiving weekend those games are
just [__] incredible oh that that
that Saturday was the best day of
football all year yeah when that
Washington that pmic kid is sick
quarterback every year you got Alabama
Auburn Ohio State Michigan uh I wish you
know what I wish the [__] West Coast
wish they had better game like USC and
UCLA they don't play on Thanksgiving
weekend do they they play they play the
weekend before now why is that who knows
it just seems you know I I honestly
don't know but they like you know we
don't want to have a night fight like
[__] yeah Thanksgiving weekend like
after dark yeah like the bloods in the
Crips probably because well dude the
West Coast like that that's the one
thing I learned when I was out here it's
like you can [__] you can really get
the [__] kicked out of you at a baseball
game out here and it's just it's no joke
no it isn't it is like back home it's
like you know you know a two two rights
and a left here it's like someone has a
knife yeah they they play with weapons
out here yeah you get stomped you know
it hasn't happened in minute but it it's
it's always it's it's there I went to a
[__] Angels game one time I thought
it was going to get stabed and that's
what's interesting cuz you know other
than like y other than Yankees Red Sox
baseball is not like a blood sport like
football or hockey is back home here
baseball there's like way more violence
than baseball out here baseball's like a
Pastime yeah you have a hot dog you know
bring your wife she reads a newspaper my
wife loves Pac Bell because she just
read the newspaper in the
sun she enjoyed the hot dogs in the
newspaper dude I've been been like
[__] Vice free since Thanksgiving I'm
not even drinking coffee you you cut
your coffee
consumption yeah dude I was just getting
heartburn I was drinking like three caps
a day so I was just like I'm going to
I'm going to knock this [__] off cold
bruise no heartburn I heard oh is that
what it is I heard it's a little better
Dr bartnik it's a little easier oh it is
yeah for some people not everybody I
read bill you do read I was reading
about the history of ice coffee this
pamphlet um no I got like a f
I actually was amazed by the level of
headache that I got and then how long it
took and then I think I went to a little
bit of a depression I mean it was a
[__] ride now I'm out of it well you
used to drink a lot of coffee I know but
I never did I never did I you know why
you have kids no old dads well yeah old
dad is no no no no the movie the movie
we were doing the movie and we were
shooting on one of the first days
somebody had a [__] you know maybe I
have covid maybe I don't test and you
know he I forget I think it was our
cinematographer I don't even [__]
remember and like the [__] was just
falling down and we were going to lose a
day and so it ended up getting stretched
out and I was like yawning and yawning
and yawning and then
Shay she goes you want a coffee and I
was like nah I hate coffee it doesn't
taste good she goes I had to wake you up
so I had a cappuccino and it was like
all right and then the next night I had
another one and then somewhere during
the editing of it it just it just
[__] you know workers will get you
when I started drinking coffee and
smoking cigarettes when I worked when I
was like 13 years old cuz the only way
you could stand around at work is if you
smoke or drink oh yeah not get yelled at
yeah you can't just stand or what are
you doing well I would be smoking if I
smoked yeah you have to
smoke I'll take cancer when I'm 60 I
just don't want to have to pick up any
more heavy [__] I'm 13 now what did you
what some the [__] you can talk about
what did you what jobs did you have well
I worked uh at Cool Springs driving
range in Pittsburgh I the first year I
was picked pied up golf balls by hand
and we would have cages we would we
would wear cages no you didn't I swear
on my grandmother what did you have on
your body cage would come down and most
of us didn't wear a cup because it was
too constricting and people it was date
night that come and hit balls at us oh
my God yeah and and it was like a it was
like Lord of the Flies it was like our
theme song was the who like I here in
the field I can't say we fight for meals
yeah and you were like most people stay
at like the 150 yard Mark but you get
all the money because it would be ranked
how many buckets you get per hour you
get bonuses so if you go up to like the
you know up to like
within 60 yards where like the little
like the date nights the chicks are
hitting the ball you just rock them in
but then I mean there'd be fights on the
te call it the T line you know someone
yeah you're you know then people be like
oh you know people try to hit you yeah
of course we know that so they'd be like
line brawls like three of us first like
five of them yeah but we're wearing C
ages and some sometimes put on the boots
and go in the fake Lake oh yeah I did
that for one year and then I kind of
graduated that then I work daytime in
the maintenance which was tough because
we would work uh like be there at like
6:00 or 700 a.m. so you just be out
partying till like 3:00 or 4: in the
morning and scared I saw somebody this
morning I saw somebody this morning
living that life they were coming out
and they had like the hoodie up in the
[__] sunglasses on and then they just
had their coffee just the way they were
holding their their coffee was still put
the thing on it they had it up here
right and then they had a little
whatever nourishment that they had and
was just standing at the red light I was
like oh that dude is [__] hung over
that's impressive all right time for a
read here look who it is everybody it's
old Helix Helix you know the Helix
lineup offers 20 unique mattresses
including an award-winning Lux
collection the mattress There's Mattress
Awards can you believe that somebody has
to go to that event the newly released
Helix Elite collection a mattress
designed for Big and Tall
sleepers and even a mattress made just
for kids so how will you know which
Helix matx wors best for you and your
body well [__] look at what you look
at now look at a
mattress if you're big and tall you know
which one to jump on take the Helix
sleep quiz and find your perfect
mattress in under two minutes everybody
is unique doesn't mean you have
something to say though and everyone
sleeps differently that's why Helix has
several different mattress models to Cho
from each is designed for specific sleep
positions and feel preferences models
with memory foam layers to provide
optimal pressure relief if you sleep on
your side models with a more responsible
foam to cradle your body for essential
support and stom this why we're losing
to the Russians right here and back
sleeping positions we just cradling
people she just give him a hammock with
a [__] voice recorder of his mother
uh plus enhanced cooling
features plus enhanced cooling features
to keep you from overheating at night
plus another plus Helix mattresses are
americanmade and come with a 10 to 15E
warranty depending on the model don't
want to take my word for it Helix has
been awarded the number one mattress
picked by GQ and Wired Magazine Helix is
offering 20% off all mattress orders and
two free pillows for our listeners go to
helixsleep.com bur and use the code H
iix Helix
partner2 uh this is their best yet and
it won't last long with Helix better
sleep starts now me and uh me me and
Rose almost got crushed by a landscaper
today flying out of a driveway I'm like
whoa cuz I had my headphones on I don't
know what he was looking at but it was
like holy hell oh in your car no me and
my me and my German Shepherd were
walking and uh cuz we were just walking
we walk fast and we would pay attention
oh was the guy hammered no it was like
he was whatever he was doing the he
might have been but he was a worker you
know he's he was in his work truck and
he just like screamed out of this
driveway and we're like whoa how are the
dogs getting along dogs are getting
along great I said when we first got
Rose a little rough patch and I Rose is
a German shepherd and then the other
Ruby is a 14 and a halfy old mut yeah
and now Rose is like an older lady she's
like three and a half now she's like the
whole neighbor everyone leaves her alone
and she's real calm and doesn't bother
anybody she just grew up but before when
they were younger they they went out a
little bit cuz Ruby's you know
Territorial and Ruby's just a badass
doesn't care and I and we had Rocky's
trainer we had Stallone's bucket's
trainer came by and he goes I don't know
ever be best friends but they they they
seem to be able to work you know I think
they'll work it out and I go I told my
wife my wife's like I don't want me to
do she's crying I go they're dogs it's
like hockey they'll figure it out on the
ice right literally they're best friends
now oh they are oh my God they're best
friends like literally like when I come
home cuz Ruby's so old she's like half
asleep Rose walks over and wakes her up
like hey Daddy's home get up
[Music]
and they both tag team my wife because
they both want they harass my wife
constantly so like if one's not pulling
their weight for like hey we can bother
mommy like then they'll wake like
they'll get each other like hey hurry up
let's go that's great hey we're going to
the Rose Bowl dude Rose B coming up I
changed my flight from Sad Man's I was
supposed to come in the next day and
relax and bokeh it's like that as soon
as I saw this SK I'm like there's no way
after going there for like 15 years in a
row I'm going to miss the one game the
only game I've wanted to see yeah M I
wanted to see Michigan I mean we've seen
we seen Alabama they came through one
time and beat the [__] out of Florida
State or something or was that Oregon I
can't remember oh I didn't remember that
was when Jameson Winston when they hit
him and he fumbled the ball and the guy
ran it back I want to say that maybe
that was Oregon we Stanford let's say
we've gone let's say we went like 13
years uh I can clearly remember like six
plays I know it's kind of ridiculous and
you know I've been sober for the last
five and I can't we haven't gone in for
a while we finally realized what we
finally realized was that continuing to
tailgate while the game went on was even
better than going to the game once
you've been to the game unless like your
team's in like this year I'm going not
even because it's a playoff it's because
it's Michigan yes and I've always wanted
to see Michigan at at the uh at the Rose
Bowl so Beckler yeah I got to yeah they
still the [__] roses up on their
shoulder pants see no coffee I'm gonna
fall asleep here and it's Alabama
Nick Sabin who knows how long this guy's
going to do how much long is he going to
do it I mean Bill we went to we went
there what five eight years ago they
already have a statue form there he's
only won like four more national
championships I mean he's a legend
people hate him I love the man I love
the man because I I've told you this
story who's in it who's in it this year
it's it's it's Bama and then Michigan
Texas and uh udub University of
Washington PMX I love that kid wow all
right it's gon to be so we just talking
to scolar brother favorite this got to
be Alabama this got to be well I mean
I'll tell you what
Texas I think Texas has a really good
chance CU I Texas beat Alabama right
Texas beat
Alabama at Alabama Texas is the one team
that can match up you know line for line
it has I will tell you this it has the
same amount of big boy dogs right you
know but if anybody beats [__] Nick
Sabin and Alabama twice in one year has
anybody ever done
that there's a there's a trivia question
maybe Georgia did
maybe maybe Georgia okay that's a good
guess maybe LSU did no we didn't not
since I've been watching them okay I
mean that's the only two that you can
think because Old Miss never then went
to the SEC I I might be wrong Old Miss
is like the only team that's ever beaten
like two years in a row besides Georgia
I think something crazy yeah I just like
the way he raises young men and I think
he puts out a nice product of people
into society and there's a well
documented Story how some kid when he
was in Michigan State you know they
wanted he did something that wasn't
heinous heinous but wasn't good they
wanted to throw him off the team and he
goes no we in we'll we'll do it in-house
the the guy now like runs a for 500
company his kids are like doing very
well it's like oh he could have caught
him from the team it' been nothing I I
just like Nick I like N I like Nick as a
person I I I don't know him but he seems
to raise good people guys at the NFL
that played for Alabama ni sain thanked
me he did no I'm joking
I'm imitating you when bartnik went to
go see [__] you remember that Andrew
when bartnik went to go see uh Top Gun
he goes you know what I liked about Top
Gun Tom Cruz thanked me for coming to
the movie I'm like what are you talking
about he thanked you he was there and he
said no they got this thing in the
beginning where Tom just goes hey I want
to thank everybody for com out the movie
Jo [__] say was talking of me it was
my favorite thing ever I thought it was
a nice touch nice touch still do it is
but I just the way I want to thank
everyone for watching uh my comedy
special and I want to thank everyone for
watching old dad's well I always liked
how you always always go like you had
that line in your wck you know and I
travel around and tell jokes to great
people like you you would always say
that I always thought that was a nice
positive thing to say to the crowd to
set the tone you know that we were uh
that we were appreciate I'm very
appreciative I I I feel bad sometimes I
leave the stage I go did I say thank you
enough like thank them for coming like
did I thank them enough cuz hey you got
to get out you got to leave your house
you got to go get a babysitter you got
to pay for parking got to deal with
other people it's not easy yeah I know I
to come listen to me but please do yeah
yeah please do dude you got all kinds of
stuff coming up then you got dates and
uh for other people listening we got in
February uh Portland Maine Empire Comedy
Club should be nice and warm that's the
second oh Port Maine's amazing in the
winter time to visit um from a from a
plane yeah oh Port I got two good coffee
spots there and uh a great place to get
something to eat too uh Bridgeport
Connecticut Stress Factory Vinnie brand
again Vinnie Vinnie keep an eye on that
guy I like Vinnie uh Houston Texas
February 24th the riot Comedy Club look
at you never been there but then we're
doing punchline Philly we're doing zany
Nashville zany Chicago we got a big show
in
Denver beun San
this is all in March you got pyy potown
soul Jes have you ever played Soul JS no
but what what is your web where can
people see these dates Joe bartnik decom
my new website is coming this week I got
a guy doing it we're finishing touches
nice oh my God I I had the I I was so
Zen about it Bill I'm proud of myself I
went through no I really am hey I
thanked me I went through like, 1500
pictures on my computer all these
pictures of us at the road Rose Bowl us
with everywhere four mass and square all
these great and then all these great
pictures of us like Louisville Sluggers
all these I put them all in these
folders send to my guy I went and got
like a chocolate milk I came back 90% of
them are not there why I I don't know my
wife is like you're an idiot she's a
rare I don't know they're not in my junk
they're not in any fold I have no idea
where they went I have none dude I have
no you have idea I didn't throw anything
I didn't I didn't you know I I literally
I went and took I took Ruby for a little
walk and I took Rose for a big walk I'm
like hey nothing you can I nothing I can
do and there's nothing there's nothing
we could do about let me ask you this is
that how you handled it in the moment
yes I yes it is God I wish I could do
that cuz I can't even tell you how much
I can relate to that like you know my
wife goes hey you know I go give me
something to to get you for for for for
Christmas all right I I I don't I I
don't know what what to get you right so
she sends me some ideas all right sends
me a bunch of stuff she goes he goes
anyone that arm no no no no but she's
just like any one thing is cool cuz I
don't want to be like get me this and I
go got it here it is you know it's going
to be some sort some sort of surprise
yes so I go to order the first [__]
thing dude the [__] I had to [__] go
through like three meltdowns just trying
to [__] order this [__] and I'm just
like why can't I just go to the [__]
store and buy some sneakers oh I know
cuz there's nothing there anymore and
then they're going to say well you know
they're going to steer me to the [__]
website and it's like I'm literally
typing in my address and they're telling
me that it that it it doesn't qualify or
whatever the [__] you're going to say
and I'm just like so now what do I do
what like what am I supposed to [__]
do and I just you know I I don't know I
I I me just trying to order my wife a
pair of sneakers which is all I was
trying to do by the end of that process
failing at that process I'm literally
screaming about how they're going to
microchip all of us and take all of our
[__] cars and when will they feel
like they have enough control like it's
it is a rabbit hole when something
doesn't work on your computer it really
is I mean like I was no but like you
just like I just lost all these photos
and memories hey you know what can you
do I don't I mean I've lost so many more
memories just from my
drinking how you been do that's some
escape button what happened there I
don't
know talk to Mr Daniels
Jack dude you got an I don't know how
you still do it dude you got a [__]
iron stomach I have a good time I I I
really
do I laugh you guys don't know why I'm
laughing about that for him to say that
he has a good time I mean
Joe I mean Jesus Christ Dude that
[__] did I tell you this we must have
told a story last last time I was you
were on here when we when we were in
Detroit when we were in
Detroit I think we did tell it somewhere
on ver pod I mean
I I all right real quickly he [__]
has some Bourbons he goes to bed naked
doesn't have his glasses on we're in
Detroit he goes gets up to go to the
[__] bathroom shuts the door behind
him and he's outside of his hotel room
completely [__] naked so I'm like
chill what' you do he's like yeah I
[__] covered my junk and he goes I
figured it was 3: in the morning no
one's going to be there and he I tell
you that he gets all the way down there
and the [__] right as he gets to the
front he's peeking around the corner
like 10 people like co-ed you know men
and women come walking and they're like
oh my he's going like no no I don't have
my key and then somehow he's disarming
they all start laughing and then the guy
goes to go with you and some woman
slapped you on your ass yeah this guy
like the guy behind the counter panicked
he come and give me a sport Cod it's
like I don't think care people care if
my shoulders exposed yeah that wasn't
and that wasn't even Joe having a good
time that was just Joe trying to take a
leak
yeah oh I've been naked a lot of places
crazy dud I I told Nia that story she
was [__] crying when I called up cuz
I couldn't even get it out I go
you she was already laughing before I
even got to the detail we like to have a
good [__] engine Joe all [__] red
sunburn coming down
[__] big naked bear what was funny
about that though was like I literally
like because I forgot silverware I ate a
steak by hand and I watched like the
Penguin game on my phone like I really
wasn't that I really can't you know how
much I can't see that's legendary oh
yeah yeah I don't drive with you anymore
oh I don't want anybody to I hate I hate
driving right I I can't I stopped going
down I got to leave my house only in One
Direction because the one street doesn't
have any lights on it I almost hit a
park car like three times I've almost
hit like a guy walking his dog you miss
him a yeah I am a Mr meoo I can't see
anything what you have glasses though I
know I wear them usually but this is you
know for camera I wear them everywhere
but like on the stage oh okay literally
everywhere I I I've been I've been
saying I've need I've needed them for 10
years I'm finally going to get them like
I can't see distance and I can't see uh
really like up close like if if I like
to hold this thing like uh yeah right
there it's then you need mine then you
need mine they go further ways on top
and then close is on the bottom just
walking around doing this all day and
then chopr it takes you like an it takes
you like three weeks or so to get used
to like looking three weeks I know and
it almost wrecked so bad I brought them
back the first time I had them I go I I
can't wear these cuz if you're driving
you see good right you're driving you
see good then all a sudden you look down
the picture you coming in you got like a
[__] tree branch sticking out of your
grill you just come this ain't [__]
working for me it was almost that it was
almost that I can't I can't I can't I
can't so and then but until you look
down at the radio then it then it's
close so then your your vision snaps
into that and then you look back up and
you're a little bit dizzy for a second I
couldn't do it on the freeway I'm like I
I return these but then like a couple
years later I went through it and just
trained my eyes to do it now it's like
perfect you can wear it takes three
[__] weeks I mean I thought it was a
couple of days and maybe a couple of
days it told it said I I do a lot it
said like three weeks and after one week
I'm like I I can't handle it but you're
the one that made me get glasses because
I was really you go bck I don't want to
see you squinting into a menu anymore oh
it's also the and then and then dude you
would you would stop like 200 yards
behind the car in front of us thinking
they were right in front of us we' be
looking Joe what are you doing and you
just sitting there okay got to go a
little
closer my wife says I ruined the brakes
in the car because it's like I slam on
the bres CU I'm all a sudden I'm there
like I think I'm I I I have no depth
perception I'm like oh I got PL SP I was
like oh they're right there I slam on
the brakes all right last thing let's
talk hockey cuz I I just with the kids
and and and trying to write a new movie
and everything I just don't I know my
Bruins are playing great I I I checked
in on your uh every time I go you know
just to randomly check in on the center
ice package [__] penguins are always
playing I always miss the night when the
Bruins are playing um well it's been a
mixed bag with Pittsburgh Penguins you
know everyone says oh they're too old
and they got Carlson and what are they
doing they're all in uh you know the the
Hall of Famers Sid and Gino have Sid's
been amazing uh goo's played pretty good
cooled off a little bit and now the goal
tending has been good but the bottom six
and they've lost a lot their power play
was 0 for 33 didn't score in a month
until last night so if their power play
was going at a decent clip they' be in
the playoffs probably right in the cusp
right now they're like six points out
plenty of plenty of Runway to go I don't
know I they don't I said beginning of
the year if they make it in the playoffs
I think they can make the playoffs I
said beginning of the year but they and
they could win a round because they got
Cino but they're not winning four rounds
of seven right but you know everyone's
like got turn over I know I I got three
staling cups from Sid Gino I love those
guys I'd rather just be mediocre and
watch them play three more years then
all of a sudden see Gino as a San Jose
Shark how how you know or see like Sid
somewhere else like let them let them go
out how old is uh Sydney now Sid's 37 I
believe G's 38 no he is he's
37 I'm almost positive play they they
they they played he came he came in the
league about 18 years old but I thought
he came in around 08 though no he came
in like
6 he came in 05 the Lo the lockout he
came in I think 05 and then Gino came
06 Sydney Crosby's 37 years old oh yeah
well you know him Sid Gino and Tanger
are the longest in North American Sports
history teammates teammates period let
Al what's amazing is they're longer than
Jeter and Bernie Williams and uh oh how
long they've been together Rivera yeah
the longest ever in North America
American history of the big four I there
might be like three soccer players from
the indoor soccer league that passed it
but and
possibly I used to love indoor
soccer oh yeah you watched that [__] oh
yeah the Pittsburgh Spirit yeah because
it's like you know it was like watching
gym class just European guys kicking the
balls off the hockey boards and coming
back at them nothing was in Bound out of
bounds yeah we had like some sort of tea
party team or the lobsters I can't
remember what the [__] they called the
revolution well that was regular yeah I
know it was I me when there was like
there used to be four channels in you
know so oh soccer's on I the biggest
bunch of crap I ever saw those was the
Pittsburgh the first year of the
national indoor lacrosse league remember
that indoor lacrosse indoor lacrosse no
well the commercial made it look like it
was you know like violence it was like
you know the 75 uh Flyers Flyers and
there was like maybe two hits the whole
game and we're just sitting there
watching these as high school kids like
what is
this we didn't we didn't have lacrosse
are the Flyers off the cup yet no that's
in in two in uh 2025 so so Joe bartnik
hates the Flyers much I'm trying to sell
tickets here
Bill actually I got to say Philly fans
going all the way back to when me and
verie did the Allin tour Philly comedy
fans and Philly people are the best I I
love them the food I love Philly
everything except the team that looks
like this oh the cre yeah you don't like
the fly but I like the uh I I've always
enjoyed Philly too I I don't know uh I
don't know what they're so upset about
they have a great City they have great
food the people there are funny amazing
yeah I don't yeah food is kind of
[__] you know I would put that up
against anything on the east coast and I
I just don't understand like like what
is the problem do you think I think they
almost feed into it like it's cool to be
that way that's what I think I just
think ESPN's been blown I think this is
my conspiracy like they act like
Philly's the worst behaved like fans
just cuz they don't want to see the
worst behaved fans which is which you
know was out here back we had like that
guy get kicked in the [__] head in
front of his kids and he that guy ended
up
dying oh yeah yeah Giants we word of San
Francisco Giants I thought he was app
died I don't know years later he did
from the from the injures so then it
then it switched to like a murder R and
his guy's kids were there he's wearing a
Giants Jersey and he got into with two
Dodger fans and he ends up being brain
dead after that and then [__] dying
so like I mean that kind of Beats I'm
not trying to get Philly to try and top
that but it's just like no but you know
what the but you know what I don't I
that's why I mean Penguins I go Kings I
I don't even wear the uh you know I
never wear like I never even wear my
sweater anymore just like you know I
don't want to be I just don't want are
the aggravation to be the team but
what's funny is I guess this I'll say
this on air Andy my pck off co-host I
guess some guy was trying to get at me I
guess he recognized me and they were
trying to get to me like to mess with me
I wasn't paying attention but they kept
bothering Andy uhuh Andy got two punches
in on
him blooded him up Andy hit him
yeah like I'm like whoa like four
penguin fans it was pretty crazy and we
won right right in overtime when Rusty
scored we won and it's like ah I was
going nuts and all of a sudden there was
like a scuffle right next like what's
going on breaking and then they called
the the goal back and then then Rush
scored like 10 seconds later so we got
to celebrate
twice we we we had lost a bunch of games
in a row at Staple Center so it was nice
to get a win but yeah but but in J but I
we wen't wearing any penguin gear like I
wasn't I mean I wore I wore like I think
a penguin hat but not like the I it's
like I'm tired of being like a a uh the
enemy in someone else's place it's like
yeah it's like I just want to watch the
game I do tell you like once a year for
like in the summer I'll go back to
Boston or maybe a different time of the
year whatever we always try
maybe if the kids have a school break
we'll go back then it always changes
when we go back but uh to just go to a
game and be not in enemy territory I
mean I've been in enemy territory sport
as far as Sports goes since
1995 it's like more than half of my life
I think at this point yeah more than
half of my I was 27 I'm 55 yeah 28 years
I'm just sick of it I would just like to
go to a [__] Celtic game and cheer
the Celtics but I live in LA I'm not you
know I'm not going to [__] go down
there and just deal with that like like
you know 99% nothing's going to happen I
don't need that [__] my family there
yeah [__] you and all this crap that
they're gonna say yeah it's it's too
much that's why like my daughter she's a
great penguin fan she like she wants to
go see Sid Gino in Pittsburgh one time
we we got to do it next year yeah
because it's like she's put up with
everything the king because she my
favorite moment ever is a father other
at least you you're not you're not like
blood Rivals with like it'd be like if
you moved to Philly I moved to New York
and like that whole Red Sox curse of the
Babe [__] oh my God that [__] and
then right as that ends I [__] move
out here and then that that's when the
Celtics bought that that 08 Championship
you know went out just no Lakers are on
your hit list with the uh no because we
were we were younger when I was always
younger but my daughter was little we
went saw Penguins played a great game
like think the last time we won until
this time they play great G squir Sid
squir there was a fight we won the fight
right in front of us like three rows
from the ice and they now it's like on
Saturday the F Flyers come to town my DG
goes can we come on Saturday and boo the
Flyers I'm like I love you she's got a
big scholarship I'm so proud of I still
think I'm proud of that moment as as a
uh penguin fan but she uh but yeah she
wants to do because you know she's a
little kid so she wants to be in the
Jumbotron she's a dancer uhhuh she's
danced for years but she's wearing like
a Crosby Jersey they're never going to
put her on the Jumbotron
right any kind of like thing that for
kids is like anti like they never helped
her you let her keep dancing you don't
want to crush your
dream you know jersey with pride your
grandfather wore that Jersey you know
all right well I have you on this this
podcast with pride this guy's one of my
favorite people in this business and one
of the [__] best uh stand-up
comedians out there right now is as far
as like if you just wanted the old
school [__] uh no no uh what was it
like the XFL where you had to go tackle
the [__] each other for the football
to start off rather than a coin flip uh
Joe bartnik will be um touring all
around the country all of these great uh
working class towns huh Columbus new
brunic uh Portland Bridgeport Houston
Philly Nashville Chicago San Francisco I
would say that's working class anymore
Denver pipy Pottstown um go see this guy
he's absolutely [__] hilarious so
proud of you Joe thank you so much the
damn thing doing the damn thing this I'm
sorry New Year's Eve Boer Von cuz then
I'm coming back Rose bow the Legends
rard yes go run into us on the golf
course see if you can hang with him
hopefully he'll have his clothes on all
right that's the Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday Morning podcast
have a great weekend you
[Music]
[__] hey what's going on it's Bill Burr
and it's time for the Monday Morning
podcast for Monday December 21st
2015 what's going on how are you hey
it's almost the end of the year did I
take time out to say
thanks thank you for being you and for
just you know bringing your Vibe um
seriously I want to thank everybody
who's been watching F is for family all
right now Netflix doesn't give out any
ratings you know only they keep them
they keep them to themselves you know
like a fat kid with
cookies you know they they don't tell
anybody what's going on so I have no
idea all I can judge by is the uh the
feedback you guys have been giving me on
Twitter Facebook and uh wherever the
hell else you guys are at and you guys
seem to be liking it so thank you so
much for watching the goddamn show
please tell your friends about it um
very happy that people are enjoying it
we worked our asses off on it so with
that let's get on with the podcast um as
you know it's really late today you know
later than it usually is um I just have
family in town and um I don't know
they're like regular people so they
sleep and
um you know they sleep and they sleep
and they sleep and I am I don't I don't
get it I mean I go to bed after I go to
bed after regular people and I wake up
before them you
know it's probably because they're like
I don't know more just at peace with
themselves so they can just keep
sleeping but my brain keeps
going the whole [__] night so I mean
I can get about 6 hours and then I got
to get up and start doing something or I
go go absolutely [__] insane so um I
wasn't able to record this morning
because everybody was still sleeping and
I had to walk around and be on
eggshells so of course I'm on the phone
with verie and we're yelling about
sports and uh my wife came out and let
me know you know you got to stop walking
around screaming at the top of your
lungs into your phone of having Sports
arguments with people you do it at all
hours of the day you have people on on
speaker and you're screaming about
sports and it's really affecting the
environment in the house now if I was a
mature adult I'd be like you know what
you're absolutely right I should be
considerate I can only imagine if you
were walking around screaming about all
the [__] you watch on Bravo TV that
unbelievably
[__] I don't just devoid of any sort
of intellect on that [__] [__] of a
channel
I swear to God if if I knew somebody in
in the CIA I bet it goes Isis and then
Bravo TV and then whoever's the f I
don't know I don't who would be the next
person they're going to go after it's
just as far as like you know [__] up
this country Isis Bravo
TV and
uh I know Bravo TVs that's a broad brush
that gets rid of a lot of people but
anyways so if I was a mature adult I
would have just been like you know what
you're absolutely right
but instead what did I say I said well
you
know you [__] sleep all day you sleep
till like you know all hours of the day
and I got to walk around Tippy Toe and
and she was just like I'm not talking
about that it's like yeah well I am I'm
talking about that why are you talking
about it because I know you're right in
the other area of the debate so I
already have a New Year's resolution no
more screaming on my phone in the house
about sports TV and there you go once
again I'll work on my myself as a human
being and slowly stop being the bill
that you know and love and I'll become
that thing they want you to be and one
day they wake up they go well the work's
done I'm bored I think I'll go blow
somebody else and you know what that's
you know that's the trajectory of most
marriages you know everything they liked
about you they start to [__] hate
then they fix it and then they do you're
somebody different then they walk down
the street just giveing handies who
wants one who gets your head jobs here
unhappily married woman coming down the
street took my dog for a walk today all
the way around the block and it didn't
[__]
once it's just you know it usually shits
like two three
times so I got all paranoid and I was
looking around the house trying to find
dog [__] I couldn't find it anywhere and
I was thinking like did it [__] its
brains out the day before so that it
just it's got nothing
left I don't know you know something
this might be one for a veterinarian
maybe I should call them up rather than
just talking out into [__] the empty
space of podcast him that's right
podcast him I did that uh fighter and
the kid Brian kin's podcast I did that
earlier today so look for that and
uh you probably wonder about Jesus Bill
why you so [__] lethargic H it
because you only get 6 hours sleep no
because me and a buddy of mine went to a
burger place that uh somebody suggested
down in Watts la as in the Watts Riots
that's the only reason why people white
people know about Watts they got a
hamburger place down there called
Hawkins and we went down there there was
three of us white as
[__] white as [__] a new show on Bravo
um and we drove down there and uh we
were all laughing just going all right
three of the whitest people ever are
going to go down to
watch you know are we going to get
mugged a second we get out of the car
are they going to think we're cops you
know all the scared white guy things and
then we showed up and we're staring at
the [__] menu and this guy just goes
hey is this your first time here and we
go yeah and then they go first timers
and everybody in the kitchen yell hey
welcome to
hains it became like an after school
special it was hilarious and then as a
white person you're like oh it really
isn't that bad I get it now most of my
thoughts are just fear-based
right and then there's always that one
dude's just got to [__] it up for
everybody right this guy showed up
[__] weird weird
vibe had uh US Air Force bag he just
sort of left it in the middle of the
area where we're eating and then walked
away from it sat in the corner was sort
of staring at us and he was eating
peanuts he wasn't eating a burger and
then he walked outside and walked around
to the open window area where we were at
and then he offered us peanuts and we
were like no thank you we would we don't
want any of your peanuts and then we
sort of finished up and we went to leave
and he was staring at us and he wrote
down our license plate
number ah it's awful it's awful what
going to war does to you but I think he
was super [__] paranoid already I'm
I'm I'm piecing it together I I
certainly wasn't going to have a
conversation with the guy I was judging
by the the the US Air Force bag and then
uh you know the paranoid
behavior and his he had something on his
his [__] wrist like he got [__] up
his wrist or something like that I have
no [__] idea but all I can tell you
is I'm going to go back there again cuz
who's the best goddamn Burger I think I
might be the best Burg I've ever had but
Jesus [__] Christ it's the size of a
football
um and you know if you're a goal
oriented person you know you're going to
get about three bites in going holy [__]
this is delicious you're going to get
halfway through and you're going to be
like do do I win a t-shirt if I finish
this thing and then finally just like
you know I I can't I got to finish this
thing H fries are delicious I got the uh
the fat burger with egg and it was
outstanding
um it's called Hawkins it's right off of
South Central I believe and uh it was
[__] delicious and I was like thank
God cuz I was bringing you know it was a
recommendation from a couple of people I
met when I I did yet another failed
pilot and uh you know I love meeting
people that are actually from Los
Angeles cuz they love Los Angeles and
then they know all the cool places to go
so um most people who are transplants
like me stay basically in the Hollywood
Valley area so I asked these guys I'm
like give me something what do you got
what do you guys all right you want to
you want to [__] you know you want to
try some go go down to Watts we went
down there it was absolutely [__]
delicious but I'll tell you this right
now I am paying for it uh there's no way
you won't if you're smart you go down
there and you'll split
one um but if you're listening to this
podcast you're probably not smart and
you're going to order one yourself and
you're going to you're going to do what
I just did and uh but it's a wonderful
experience until you get right to the
end and your body keeps saying stop it
stop it what are you doing stop it and
you just can't you just keep [__]
shoveling it in your face and then
you're just leaning on something you're
leaning on something you're like why did
I just do that oh my God I got to be on
the [__] elliptical for 9 years and
then all of a sudden a [__] Air Force
veterans offing your peanuts and you
want to stay say no you want to stand up
straight look like you're somebody that
can't be [__] with you know
and you just can't do it you just lean
in there and then maybe it comes off his
confidence and maybe that's why he
leaves you alone I have no [__] idea
but
um oh my God my mouth is dry there with
so much [__] salt in me right
now you
know Jesus Christ but you know what it
was worth it I was actually psyched I
went down there I watched this great
documentary which of course I can't
remember the name of it but Forest wh
did the uh the uh the narration on it it
was all about um the history of Los
Angeles and the gangs and all of that
stuff and police violence and everything
and um it actually broke down all those
different areas you always hear about it
you know how many people saw Straight
Out of Compton and actually know where
where Compton is you know what I mean
it's
ridiculous it's one of the great groups
of all [__] time you should know
where it is and La is just so [__]
weird like that they pave over their
history they don't [__] tell you
where anything is it's all about the
highways take the 405 to the 10 you guys
ever watch that SNL sketch The
Californians right they'd be like
Devin there like that sketch was so
[__] accurate as far as like
everybody's obsessed with like uh where
did you come from and where do you live
and it's always oh I took the 105 to the
110 to the
60 you know got off at [__] M
Holland it's all Obsession about how to
get uh how you got somewhere because of
this [__] hellacious traffic so
anyways I am
uh I'm full of salt right now I am not
going to eat again until breakfast
tomorrow ah
[__] oh but it was worth it it was
[__] worth it I had like one bite of
that and I'm like I'm bringing Nia here
tomorrow and then I got halfway through
the burger and I was like I am bringing
Nia here in about a month and then I
finished it and I was just like in six
months when I'm not full when I'm not
full again I'm so [__] full right now
I can't even finish my
sentences oh was glorious it's really a
feeling that so few people in the world
know most people are starving you know
so I'm trying to feel privileged right
now even though I it's a big part of me
wants to kill
myself oh it hurts the
laugh Jesus Christ that was Thanksgiving
between two buns it was [__] my buddy
one of my buddies had a p Army Sandwich
he said I'm three bites in I still
haven't made it to the bun he was smart
enough to stop me and my other friend
just we just kept going and he had to
[__]
drive oh I wanted to I wanted to recline
the seat so [__] bad but I was afraid
that if I reclined it was all going to
come
up all right Bill enough you talked
about dog [__] and overeating is
this supposed to be exciting well it's
that time of year it's that time of year
when you can say come on and eat a man
ho size [__]
Burger it was incredible um so anyways
what's why don't we uh why don't we talk
about some [__] other than dog [__]
and uh me eating an oversized Burger um
ah my stupid password I can never reopen
thing still [__] it up uh how about
the uh how about those New England
Patriots huh sort of limping
along um I don't think we're going to do
any damage this year I I really I just
don't think it's our [__] year man we
just have too many injuries and uh I
watched the Giants
Panthers as I I mentioned I when I was
promoting the FIS for family last week I
got to do Rich Eisen show I called in
and I was talking about how I thought
the Giants Panthers game was going to be
the game of the week as far as either
the Giants turn the [__] corner like
they always seem to in December and make
one of those great playoff runs despite
their
record um or the Panthers are going to
basically go undefeated and win the
Super Bowl that's what the [__] I was
saying of course who what the what do I
know I'm just a comedian but I watched
the game it was a great game and of
course everybody was freaking out about
Odell Beckham and I was that guy
Norman um I can't believe Beckham didn't
get [__] ejected you know what I mean
I swear to God that was [__]
unbelievable however though a lot of me
I really enjoyed it I love them getting
in each other's fa I I didn't like him
lying launching him helmet to helmet
that type of hit but uh I was talking to
another friend of mine I said it
reminded me of Mel blunt and Golden
Richards back in the day except Golden
Richards fought
back
um but it's interesting cuz Beckham kind
of acted like a big [__] baby cuz he
wasn't getting any catches just cuz he
got roughed up a little bit and uh I
kind of agree with uh what I hope I'm
saying his name right Beckham was it not
a Beckham I mean uh Norman right
ah [__] but why don't you look up [__]
before you [__] start talking about
it then you got to type with one index
finger and that's not fun for anybody
right um yeah Josh Norman he said he
kind of cracked the cat on him you get
under his skin a little bit so I think I
think more people are going to try to
[__] with Beckham cuz God knows if you
just try to cover him you can't you
can't do
it but once again the football Gods love
the Giant
they love them how the [__] do you get
away this guy ran like [__] 30 yards
and just jumped in the air head first
into another guy's [__] Helm I guess
because it was away from the play they
didn't see it um three personal
fouls I don't know you know what it
really comes down to as you know much as
all you [__] oh the [__] Brady rule
there really is the Superstar rule if
you're a [__] Superstar you can throw
that guy out of that
game you know you could do it he's one
of the superstars they they need to make
their money first and then about 50
other things and then they try to
protect the players cuz even now that
the fact that they're trying to protect
players why are they protecting they're
protecting their wallets now that
everybody there wallets what's that
from no you are looking at a man that
doesn't judge another man by the size of
his
wallet come on what movie [__] Wall
Street dude Chie she doing that scene
with his [__]
father with Martin Sheen right old Bud
Fox um anyways but I was texting back
and forth between verie and Giannis
papus and uh you know they kept doing
this you know this you know when the
Giants were coming back this is New York
this is what New York does and I was
just writing Eli is from Louisiana you
know that state that part of the country
that all New Yorkers look down
on you know he's he just country boy
from Louisiana that's who the [__] he is
all right he's yet another non- New
Yorker who came to New York and took
over because when you look at the
competition come on man you know I'm
just talking about white people here
okay I'm not talking about other [__]
ethnicities cuz I I don't know what you
guys are bringing to the table I don't
pretend to know every once in a while I
listen to your music I tap my toes and
that's about the extent of it oh maybe I
come down and eat your food that's about
it but other than that I'm pretty
[__] white so all I know is the white
people in New York and generally
speaking you
know it's not it's not real deep most of
those [__] down Wall Street are not
from New York they jerk off fin Finance
Majors from all around the country go
down there and start gnawing on the bone
and what does New York do about it they
don't do a [__] thing they went from
gangs in New York where people just
walking around with hatchets and [__] to
to now it's just it's a [__] Cake
walk it's like when uh Pacino said this
is like one big [__] waiting to get
[__] that's what New Yorkers
and then if you go there and you succeed
then they say you're a New Yorker you
know what I mean padded New York is such
peeds it's [__] ridiculous nowadays
at least with white people I'm telling
you you know what I mean a lot of great
rappers obviously and basketball stars
and that type of [__] have come from New
York but other than that white people I
generally speaking The Average White New
Yorker I'm telling you he just he's not
bringing it he's standing outside of a
tad Stakes you know and his
sweatpants got his little [__] Sony
Walkman on listening to Alicia Keys New
York concrete
sub you know thinking you're a part of
it you're not a part of it you just
you're just one of the ants running
around Frank sinatras from Hope oen New
Jersey he's bridge and [__] tunnel
and he came in and took over your
[__]
City all right Eli Manning breathes
through his [__] mouth and he he
looks he looks like a 5-year-old a
football uniform he he just does this
guy no Style no the man wears Dockers
for Christ's sake and he comes in there
and look at
him he's lining up under
Center um anyways why am I [__] all
over him I actually [__] love the
Giants um I do have to tell you though
uh jpp that [__] you know that WAP
that he now has on his hand that looks
like he's holding a [__] frying pan I
swear to God if somebody on the Patriots
deflected one pass with that that
[__] thing it would be illegal and we
would lose draft picks and I'm I'm doing
that every week from now on that's going
to be my new [__] thing I'll tell you
right now if we did it we'd be
[__] did you see when he he knocked
down that pass with the [__] bulk of
that that bandage on his wrist I'm
telling you that's his new move rather
than sacking the wasting his energy
sacking the quarterback you just hold up
that giant [__] stop
sign it's an incredible you know
obviously it's [__] tragic and I I'm
trying to make light of it because I I I
honestly feel you know it's just [__]
horrible that that accident had to
happen but you know then all of a sudden
the team you want to win throws a ball
and he [__] puts his hand up you know
all the sympathy goes out the window you
like dude what the [__] is that thing
that's
legal he's like holding up one of those
giant light bulbs you know that use in
science
experiments
um anyways I mean it's almost as big as
my head I'll tell you if you could
somehow wrap my head around your [__]
hand you know and stuck it up you you
would you would lead the league in uh
past defenses is that what they call him
I don't know what they call him all I
know is I really enjoyed that war
between uh Norman and uh Odell Beckham
and I love that Norman called him a
[__] at the end of the game and I don't
think he should be fed obviously Odell
should you know you can't jump off your
[__] feet like that doing a sailor's
dive into the side of somebody's [__]
uh ear hole
what are you thinking you know what I
mean but I swear to God it reminded me
of Mel blunt and Golden Richards Golden
Richards had blonde hair just like Odell
Beckham you know no you don't know that
well well you know something I do
something I like to think
about um oh [__] I'm so goddamn full
this is so stupid Bill why why why did I
do this by the way I always I always
forget to do this the uh the podcast
email ladies and gentlemen the podcast
email is Bill at the mm podcast
.c
Bill atth MMP
podcast.com
um oh my God I'm sorry guys I got to
keep [__] drinking water I'm so full
of [__] salt right
now I'm just talking to buddy of mine he
thought he had a
tapeworm I swear to
God this should be you know what you
know what you know what sell like
[__] hot cakes right around this time
of
year tapeworms that were almost at the
end of their lives and if you could just
somehow force it down you know and just
during the holiday season you eat like a
[__] animal and it eats 90% of the
nutrition and then it just [__] kills
over and dies like Marlin Brando when
he's out in the garden with his son you
know or his
grandson wouldn't that be great then you
could just eat and drink like a [__]
maniac and this tapeworm just takes it
all and then it dies and then you know
for the next couple of weeks when you
have to go to the potty you just don't
turn around and
look this is the most disgusting [__]
podcast I've ever done I'm sorry I
started off with dog [__] I mean where
do I go you can't make a comeback you
might as well burrow a little further
into it
right um is there anything worse than
when you go out to take your dog in a
[__] hour and a half hike and you
realize you only have one [__] bag left
you know then you got to make that
decision I'm either going to leave some
I'm going to leave some behind like
William defo and platoon or I'm going to
have to get try to get
creative and there [__] in the bag and
then you got to drop the [__] out under
the new [__] and then you just [__]
it's just it's it's a [__]
nightmare oh God how gross can this
become I just is there any women still
listening this is disgusting you like
this guy you think this guy's funny shut
up
Margaret shut up all right
any any woman right now yelling your
husband or boyfriend right now you need
to stand the [__] down okay you know
what you're going to make him do this
[__] holiday season let the man
listen to a [__] podcast for Christ's
sake look at him he's going to die eight
years before you can can you have a
heart and be nice to him on average he's
going to die eight years before
you that's the deal unless you're like
Dick Van djk 90 years old and he's still
dancing still got the light in his eye
man the [__] guy was sharp as hell I
think that's the key to it he
dancing is it I don't
know maybe figuratively dancing in your
heart walking down the street just still
hearing the birds chirp sorry oh my god
oh
[__] I'm going to take a you know what I
might walk down to the comedy store
tonight and then I'm going to get all
the way down there bill you want to go
on stage I can't I can't I'm just going
to turn around and walk back
you know what that's a great idea what
do I care I don't have any [__] new
ideas right now do I I don't think I did
I think I had that maybe I got a couple
two or three I have no idea hey how
about I read a little bit of advertising
for you guys huh you think I read bad
when I [__] regular day forget about
when I got a whole Giant Burger in me oh
my God it was good holy [__] [__] was
it
delicious I can't wait to go back you
know is it all right to just be buic
every once in a while that would have
been a great time to do it oh my God
that was
delicious right [__] puke for a
minute
straight oh man I got to pay my [__]
taxes you sons of [__] um you know be
one thing if they actually fixed the
pothole on the on my [__] road you
know be one thing if they did that I'm
going sound like an old man right now
um anyways I did a uh as I
mentioned oh
[__] this really is not a good feeling
man it was delicious people but you know
I I just I recommend not doing a podcast
right after you [__] eat one of these
goddamn
things
um oh my God so anyways like I mentioned
I did uh I did fighter in the kid
podcast today and when Brian Callum
wasn't talking about his amazing
athletic physique I was talk trying to
talk to a professional fighter uh
Brendan
sha I hope I said his last name
correctly um and I was just fascinated
with the ability to slip a punch and how
they just stare at the center of your
chest and look for some movement in your
shoulders and they're able to somehow
slip the [__] punch it was amazing to
me we talked about cauliflower ears and
at what point you're not you can't drain
them anymore cuz I guess initially it's
blood and then it turns all [__]
had
um I don't know that's probably more
interesting than anything that I [__]
talked about but anybody fights for a
living man I wanted to talk more about
that I hope I get to do the podcast
again cuz if there's just a way to get
Brian K to stop talking about himself
there's somehow a way to do that um I
had a lot of interesting questions but
you know Brian somehow gets himself in
between you and the interesting thing
that could actually happen and he just
you
know has to talk about his uh geometric
shape which I believe he described as an
upside down triangle being screwed into
uh something else I don't know manly
an old TV tube I forgot how he described
his lower portion of his body but you
know it was just one description after
another about his amazing physique I'm
[__] with you obviously I love Brian
Ken um so listen to that this week and
uh with that why don't I get into the
[__] questions before I literally
fall
asleep all right uh Terry Reid everybody
I don't know who that is I know what tar
re is Terry re hey there Billy billbo
Baggins just wondering if you ever heard
of Terry
Reid uh he was offered by Jimmy pagee to
be the frontman to his new Yard Birds y
birds banned and said that he had a
couple of guys that would be better for
the job Robert Plant and John bonam I
love this story and I love Terry's music
if you hadn't heard his stuff check out
seed of
memory uh to be treated right and Dean
are my favorites I guess there's a
documentary super lungs is coming out
soon anyways I've never heard you
mention him before and thought it'd be
right up your alley oh well that's
amazing you know there's a bunch of
those kinds of [__]
stories like somebody sent me one
recently I think I might have talked
about it about a guy who filled in for
Ringo's star for like two weeks at the
height of beetle Mania Ringo had like
tonsilitis or something and of course it
was the early 60s so it was damn near
fatal you know what I mean he had you
had to like [__] go to some witch
doctor or some [__] to get cured so they
had this other guy sit in and he went
from complete nobody to being totally
famous in every chick in the world that
couldn't [__] lennin McCartney or
[__] Harrison was jumping on his dick
and then the whole [__] thing ended
two weeks later and no one knew who he
was and he was just like what the [__]
was
that um and I guess you know he didn't
want to make a docu out of it but uh
recently I was I was going through
Twitter and they showed a picture of him
this great
picture it's great for me looking at it
to to get a sense of what it was like
after he was in The Beatles probably
crushing for him he was
sitting in a um at an airport waiting
for a uh a flight and he was like the
only guy there just sitting there by
himself with his Beatles haircut they
made him get a Beatles haircut and wear
like a [__] Ringo style suit and then
he was just like what what what the [__]
happened within two years he was broke
and out of the music business
um they just kind of lifted him up and
gave the old right there Fred right back
down um kind of incredible so I always
find that amazing when there was like
people that were
uh you know in bands in fact I remember
a long time ago I was trying to develop
this script but of course I just I have
too much add to try to get these [__]
ideas off the ground I had an idea for
uh for a movie and then they ended up
kind of doing the movie already with
uh with one of those guys from the
office but my idea was you know I used
to watch those um Those Behind the
musics and there was always
somebody oh [__] it comes the itis um oh
that Burger's taking me down um there
there's U there's always that person
early on you know they're like in ACDC
and they decide to quit and go to school
or they get married and then the band
goes on to make it and I always thought
like whatever happened to that [__]
guy got to spend the rest of his life I
don't give a [__] what he does he can be
a [__] brain surgeon people still
like dude you quit
ACDC oh my God what a [__] loser for
the rest of your life so I had this idea
for a movies it was basically it was
about a guy that quit a band and went on
to make it and it was all about his I
think I wrote it for Adam Sandler
because it was the late 90s when I was
writing this thing and it just it was a
[__] mess I was never able to land it
and basically what happened was he ends
up meeting the devil in a bar and he
sells his soul to go back in time to not
quit the
band so he stays in the band he ends up
not meeting the love of his life and
then he ends up discovering that the
reason why the band made it was because
he quit and the right person got into
the band so he lost his
the love of his life and the band didn't
make it he [__] them all up and uh and
he was going to go to hell and uh
interestingly enough that's where my
script went to hell cuz I the way I got
out of it was then he didn't give a [__]
he was going to hell he [__] went out
of his way to find the [__] guy who
should have been in the band so then the
band makes it and uh because he did that
selfless thing there was a loophole in
selling your soul real Disney [__]
ending and he gets he doesn't have to
sell his soul gets back with his wife
and then they go to the concert in the
end oh this is how I should have done
and he's like you know what man I
wouldn't trade being with you sweetie
for all the [__] free [__] in the
world the end right and they kind of
made a movie like
that um or enough of it either way I
don't give a [__] right so anyways
getting back to this Terry Reid guy
uh what was I going to say um that
sounds very interesting I'm actually you
know I'm going to [__] put this guy
in right now now to look him up Terry
Reid man that sounds like a country guy
was that Jerry Reed he's found down
loaded up and
[__] um wife's you know we said that
one night when he was just sick of
singing that song in front of those
[__] churchgoing racing racist
[__] country music
fans oh God they love talking about
family I'll tell you right now if I
wasn't white I would not hang around
with any white people that talked about
the family values the second white
people start talking talking about that
[__] you just know it's you know what's
underneath that good family values you
know founding
fathers all right let's let's let's not
get too political here Bill all right
wife's brother found picture I posted
online my wife's brother found a picture
I posted online okay obviously it's not
going to be too good first off go [__]
yourself all right thank you very nice
to see you too um oh wait I forgot to
read what this person wrote at the end
just uh binge drinking watching F is for
family right now so far I love it it
mirrors the anger I have inside but
can't let out in a modern day Society
thanks for all the free content and is
always go [__] yourself all right there
another guy watching after his family
W um all right this next guy my wife's
brother found a picture I posted online
all right first off go [__] yourself hey
stop being mean oh by the way did
anybody see Will Farrell on Jimmy Fallon
the tonight's show this week
doing that uh I got to give you a link
to this even though it already has 12
million [__]
views
um Will Farrell is the new Santa Claus
and he's like a like a Santa
bro um I I can't do it justice I can't
do he's kind of got a high pitch hey
Jimmy he's got this [__] blonde wig
on with the soul patch I've watched that
it's like a [__] 10-minute video I've
already watched it like four times I
hate to say this I was actually watching
it while driving the other day just
laughing you know it's [__] traffic
out here you know but uh you got to see
it it's the fact that it's just a
one-off character and then he came out
and crushed that hard with
it the guy's an absolute genius and by
the way he has a movie coming out called
Daddy's home starring Mark
Walberg Boston's own Mark wallberg and
uh Yours Truly has a quick scene in
there I got a quick scene don't blink or
you'll miss me but that comes out on
Christmas day so if you already saw Star
Wars which is hilarious I heard it's
[__] awesome and now I want to go see
it after me trashing
it um verie was [__] defending it was
trying to say Star Wars is not a nerd
movie which is like me saying the New
York Yankees aren't a baseball team like
it's it's not only a nerd movie it's
like a nerds nerd movie you know what I
mean that's like saying Good Fellas is
not a gangster movie it's it's more
about interpersonal relation
ships um yeah it's a total [__] Nerd
movie but it's it's fine it's okay to be
he's defending it going like talking
about what a great jump shot he has and
how he can throw a football like an
animal ah love verie he's always talking
trash man is always talking trash um so
of course I got to be a [__] I wrote him
back on Facebook I'm going Paul not for
nothing but when there's there's full
grown adults dressing like the
characters in the movies that you got to
expect you're going to get little bit of
[__] right cuz he's trying to do going
to be so negative can't people just have
a good time
man um I think it's the fact that the
first four like three out of four were
either mediocre or absolutely horrific
and people would rather line up and
watch that [__] and there's all truly
amazing movies truly amazing Cinema out
there all right uh White's brother found
pick that I posted online first off go
[__] you I'll cut to the chase be nice
if I did I've started this letter like
three times I'm 22 and married married
jeez with two children one is
biological that that word always reminds
me of Sha's rap cuz his biological
didn't bother remember that he was
bobbing his head of course they got him
a convertible cuz he's like 9 ft tall uh
I got a little I got a little too [__]
face the other night and I shared skimpy
pictures of my wife's awesome
ass on I can't tell where
you got a little shitfaced you got a
little too shitfaced
long story short my wife's brother was
also on there and came across these
pictures my wife was passed out drunk
and I drew a
monster eating a hot dog coming out of
her ass before taking the pictures dude
this isn't
real I don't want this to be
real so then you posted it on a porn
site and it turned out your
brother-in-law was on
there or your your girlfriend's brother
was on there what the what the [__] is
going on oh
brother-in-law this is that's actually a
happy ending that the circle of you
three ended right there and you guys
just swirl around in an Eddy of that
[__]
nonsense thank God that didn't go out
into Humanity like like a
virus he goes my wife was passed out let
me read this again my wife was passed
out drunk and I drew a monster eating a
hot dog coming out of her ass before
taking the
pictures uh her brother is coming to
town for the holidays and I'm curious
what you would do in this situation well
how the [__] did he know it was his
sister's ass he was scrolling through uh
look at that ass.com and then all a say
he was just like
Karen or do you have your own name on
this porno site or would you do it on
Facebook this is really weird you know
what this is this might be one of the
few Law and Order episodes that were
never made
don't then he shows up you're like hey
that was just a joke and then he [__]
did he did he kill you did the wife kill
you who knows
um all right her brother's coming to
into town for the holidays I'm curious
what you would do in this
situation uh you mean I don't know but
aside from kill myself uh I don't know
her brother already doesn't care for me
and I'm expecting an ass
beating if he starts hitting me can I
hit him back or just become a punching
bag for the
evening uh how old are you you got kid
he's
22 wait you
you're sir you've made a series of bad
decisions in life and it's ended with
this and I think it's it's great that
the year is ending that you're in this
situation and I would try to do
something to get out of
it h the first thing I'd do I'd stop
drawing pictures on my wife's ass and
putting them on the Internet secondly I
would take some self-defense
classes and uh put my wife's brother in
his place but he's going to be right on
this
one the only way he knows at your wife's
ass is if somehow your name is connected
to that account so I'm guessing you went
on Facebook for friends and family and
your [__] wife's ass with the hot dog
coming out of it that's really weird it
probably look like [__] [__] didn't
it you were drawing a [__] turd
coming out of our
ass um yeah for brother if anybody
starts hitting you can always hit back I
just try to tie him up just get him in a
bear hug and just get your mouth in his
ear going I'm sorry dude I'm sorry I'm
sorry Joey I'm sorry just keep doing
that maybe that'll work I have no idea
that's a hell of a predicament anyways
he goes thank you for eff for family
it's the only show that is funnier than
South Park hey easy easy no it isn't
South Park's the king I love the podcast
and of course the advice go [__]
yourself as much as I I've [__] myself
well good luck with that one
um
vinyl uh dear William Claus I'm buying a
couple of friends SL relatives some
vinyl this year for Christmas need some
help I want to get a couple of classic
rock and jazz albums do you are Nia or
the dude who does your
podcast or even your m man have any
suggestions well I think Bill bur live
at Andrew's house is a hell of a that's
a hell of a record to own personally
speaking I I think it's phenomenal if I
do say so myself
um what what what kind of
uh what kind of kind of jazz you want to
listen to I mean you can go with the
classics if you just going come out you
know you have the ones that everybody
gets who try like even the people try to
pretend like they're into jazz like me
know you know like uh God what are those
Miles Davis ones Bera
cool the one with My Funny Valentine on
it might be that
one
right John col trainer Love Supreme
that's that's
[__] you know sounds like a baby
playing a [__] saxophone to me if it
actually knew what it was doing but
didn't understand how to make sentences
yet
um I always like Miles Davis in a silent
way uh classic rock albums come on man I
don't know Zeppelin
2 uh ACDC Back in Black I don't know I
don't know what to tell you I don't know
I got a giant burger sitting in me and
it's slowly you know you know what I
feel like I feel like this must be what
it's like after you get bit by a
poisonous snake after the pain is gone
and the horror is gone the serpent has
left the area and you just given into
the fact like hey man I'm just going to
ride this out I'm going to start
hallucinating and I might wake up dead
in some other place or I might just die
right here right now
um I saw something so I can't even talk
about it like I saw something so [__]
up the other day I was watching one of
those animal Clips I hate animals that
don't have the decency to kill another
animal before they start eating it you
know reptiles are big on
that I saw reptile one time you know
those giant bulls that [__] routinely
kill Lions this kodo Dragon [__] bit
it in the leg and it's got such bacteria
in its in its mouth that it knows it's
going to get into the Bull's [__]
blood system and it's just going to
collapse but it takes like 3 days so
this lizard just keeps following this
thing around waiting for it to collapse
not die collapse and then it comes up
and just starts eating its guts as the
[__] cows just it's horrific I don't
know why I'm bringing that up you know
what I brought that up let's see if I
can make you laugh after that [__]
image huh all right TV show TV show
recommendations
um number one hey Billy Bob Red [__] hey
Billy Bob Red [__] how's it going that's
actually a good one I [__] it up I
have a show you need to watch it's
called Ray dunan starring uh leave
Shriver it's about a Boston family that
moves to LA and leave why you acting
like this isn't a massive [__]
uh a massive hit plays a fixer for
celebrities and high-profile people in
the city It's [__] amazing I know
you'd like it it's got boozing banging
tits and death the four components of a
sick show take a watch you won't be
disappointed thanks for all the podcasts
always gets me through the day go [__]
yourself um actually I'm going to start
watching that show because um a good
friend of mine Mike B
um who directed black or white who's
become one of my really good friends and
uh he's actually signed on to start
writing on that show and uh I was
talking to him the other day he says he
wakes up early excited to go to work
he's loving working on the show and he
was telling me how sick some of the
shows are that they're making right now
so I'm definitely I'm going to try to
get caught up on that one so thank you
for the recommendation do you have any
more oh look at that recommendation
number two two two all right uh dear
Billy sluth the 2009 BBC Sherlock Holmes
TV show starring Benedict Cumberbatch is
awesome the acting is great great and
it's shot well there are only four
seasons four episodes per season very
well done it's on Netflix and there are
a couple of season you know I'm going to
give that a shot Sherlock Holmes was
always really dry cuz he's so [__]
cerebral I like those cops that you know
they smack people around you know what I
mean and then drink and [__] they solve
[__] the way you know the way people who
aren't smart do you
know they get themselves liquored up and
they use uh violence I like watching
that [__] so I I'll sit with that you
know I always feel like Sherlock Holmes
is like Europe's Doctor Who but if
there's only four episodes per season I
think I can do that all right number
three oh this burger Berg is taking me
down I don't know if I'm going to make
it guys this might be my last Monday
Morning podcast I want to thank all you
guys for listening over the last decade
hey Bill my speech is slowly going to
become slurred my vision is beginning to
double I won't be able to go on with the
others is this How It Ends all right hey
Bill not sure if you've seen the Nick
yet but it's a great show Clive Owen is
great he's a heroin SL Coke addict
Doctor Who does experimental surgeries
in 1901 H Jesus Christ I'm on board
every time my wife and I watch it we
always say Jesus Christ oh oh oh Jesus
Christ the way you do because of the
crazy [__] that goes down give it a
watch and allow yourself to say the same
thing thanks for the laughs all right
I'll try that number four dear Bill have
you heard of this new show F is for
family why know I have not wink wink let
me read let me read the description it's
voiced by the redheaded the red head
from I love the80s Strikes Back Bruce
D's daughter does a voice too it's an
accurate portrayal of life in the 70s
filled with all types of humor the
language is a bit salty so make sure not
to watch it on Sundays I heard they
signed for four and a half more seasons
so don't expect to see the red head on
VH1 anytime soon love you man thanks for
the laughs ah wasn't that sweet that was
a nice little gift there wasn't it all
right winding down
here oh you know I told myself the other
day I was going to wrap the Christmas
gifts and just [__] just put this
whole Christmas thing to bed you know
cuz the next few nights I'm going to a
bunch of Christmas
parties and uh you know what I mean oh
God why did I do that burger today then
I got all these Christmas
parties you
know all right you know what I'm going
to do I'm going to [__] the second
I'm done with this [__] I'm and I upload
this podcast I'm shoving my giant head
under some water and I'm waking the up
and I'm going to go to the gym I'm going
to go to the gym every day it's just
become a part me life and if you know
want a be F where you go to the gym
every day you
[__] um all right dilemma here is a
dilemma for you dear Bill dear billam uh
my girlfriend said no gifts for
Christmas she looked me dead in the eye
and said please no gifts this year wow
that's great to give give you the
backstory we got engaged a month ago and
are also going to London in February
she's not the type of girl to [__]
about this or test me like some psycho
she really meant it oh oh this this is
this is a tough one I was thinking about
making her a card or something lame SL
awesome like that what can I do that
doesn't count as a gift but still says I
needed to give you something um all your
listeners are probably going to suggest
giving her the dick
there you go I think that's a great idea
this is what you
do you go out and you buy a little
thread that you can tie into a bow you
wrap it you tie it around your [__]
dick and then you put on some Christmas
music oh here comes Santa Claus Here
Comes Santa Claus right down Santa Claus
Lane and you just you just run in like
high kicking with your junk just
flapping in the wind with with the bow
around it right if you do that I bet
you'll never have have to buy her
anything else for Christmas again cuz
she'll probably leave you and there you
go all your problems will be
solved I don't know do you think she
really means
it you know don't buy me anything for
Christmas oh
God do they ever say what they
mean it's always a game it's always a
test they're they're higher thinkers
they're higher level being they speak in
metaphors wrapped up in an enigma with a
riddle and something else from [__]
JFK strikes back with the Empire
whatever it is
um what what could you get
her why don't you just make her
breakfast wearing a Santa hat something
simple like
that you know why you know why I don't
buy this cuz it's never enough even if
you go out you get him some [__] it's
not going to be there's always something
something needs to be worked on
something needs to
happen what do we doing here um oh [__]
that was me sitting up I just made that
noise you know somebody sent me a
[__] video of this drummer I never
heard of and I'm going to [__] send
you his name's Charles something or
other he's a jazz drummer and he is an
absolute [__] monster and he's really
fun to watch for any drummers who listen
to this I don't think drummers listen to
this for anybody happens to be a drummer
but you [__] listening to this uh let
me see if I can get the [__] name
here what is the name of this
[__] what is the name of this
[__] the guy's name is Charlie
Antolini Charlie Antolini
um I actually got this
uh I got it this morning somebody sent
it to me might or might not have been I
want to drop a name here but he may or
may not be the drummer from truth and
Salvage Company he sent it to me
and he was like check this [__] guy
out and he's a monster so I'm I'm going
to have this clip up on the podcast to
get your little drummer [__] going on
but uh I'm going to dunk my [__]
giant
head underneath the
[__] the water right now that this is
this is it guys I can't I'm trying to
get to an hour I got another [__] 3
minutes I mean technically I work for
myself so I I can take off early right
it's the [__] holidays I've been
sticking with that Mike Johnston um bass
drum workout workout by sticking with it
I mean I've done it 2 days in a row he
recommends at least 5 days a week for 3
months for 15 minutes you do his bass
drum [__] workout and then you too
will have a faster bass drum foot than
anyone in your
neighborhood I don't know unless they're
doing the workout too so I really want
to stick with
it um and I feel like if I don't go
today I'm going to [__] the whole thing
up uh I got to do it it I have to do it
and that's what I'm going to go to as
always if you would like to support this
podcast and really not do anything while
you're doing your Christmas shopping
this year if you go to
amazon.com uh a way to donate to this
podcast that doesn't cost you a damn
scent is to oh I'm fading I'm fading is
to um go to my website Bill bird.com
and you click on the merch page not the
merch page the podcast page we have an
Amazon link you click on that [__]
thing it takes you to Amazon I get
credit for driving traffic to amazon.com
you go out you buy something they kick
me a little thank you thank you and uh
then it's all good it's all good and
then uh you know I always you know every
once in a while I take some of that
money I throw it at something like St
Jude hospital and then next thing you
know every [__] charity in the world
goes oh we got a live one we got a live
one and next thing you know I get a
bunch of [__] junk mail and I have to
save the whole [__] planet I'm
sitting there go well why did I do that
I just helped out some kid with cancer
and then then they then they [__]
chopped down 50 trees selling me more
[__] here so that kid's going to get
cured and he's not going to have a
[__] tree to hang his swing on you
know what I mean you just it just
doesn't work it doesn't work you know I
had a [__] up conversation with
somebody today about you know I was
watching one of those space you know
those [__] scientist guys they were
talking about how there's like
30,000 Earths out there in space you
know inhabitable places like this with
water and all that [__] but you know
they just don't have an Epcot Center so
you know it's not earth right and
everybody always thinks well maybe
there's a bunch of human beings running
around there and I was thinking maybe
there's some dinosaurs up there maybe
the asteroid never hurt you know never
hit and maybe human beings you know
crawled out of the [__] out of the
trees mud whatever the [__] they did and
uh they got eaten you know by the trosa
rexus right and then then then they're
up there [__] eating all the [__]
trees and [__] you ever think stuff like
that well well you know something I do
ah [__] 20 more seconds 19 more seconds
18 more seconds all right Have Yourself
a Merry Little
Christmas Even if you're not
Christian I hope you had a happy Hanukah
or k Quanza and if you're Muslim I don't
know what it is you celebrate all right
that that's it a I made an hour there
you go old Billy Food Bag here I I'm
done go [__] yourselves I'll talk to see
you on Thursday all right see
[Music]
you it's the uh all right everybody it's
the uh bed MGM Sportsbook the best live
lines out there guys and how does it
work very easy you download the bmgm
Sportsbook app you sign up and you use
our code bonus code bur that's B RR and
you deposit at least $10 into to your
bet MGM account um place your first
wager and receive up to 1,500 back in
bonus bets if the BET loses if the BET
does lose your bonus bets will be
available once your initial wager is
settled so all you got to do put 10
bucks in have a little fun bet
responsibly and uh here we go into week
16 which will be my first pick oh Paulie
had his first I had my first losing week
bill in seven weeks I lost uh and it was
because of the [__] Eagles I put I
thought the Eagles were gonna write the
ship in Sneaky Pete's building and it
did not happen Oh I thought you took
Sneaky
Pete I I left a message on your phone
saying that was a great pick no I didn't
take sneaky P you know me a good team I
just Sneaky Pete I just he's not my
thing okay but uh all right I no so
anyway week uh you had a winning week
our producer themess CR rushed it this
week and um I had another tie all right
here we
go going into week 16 my pick this you
know what man Paul ver picking for Paul
let's talk about last
week um how about the Chargers the way
they just quit on their coach they were
playing like flag football oh that
transcended Sports
Paul that made me ashamed dude it was 59
to7 when I looked up after kickoff dude
I never seen I mean that was they just
quit they just quit I had the Raiders so
I mean it was an easy day for me easy
night for me but I mean to send your
coach out like that I don't know I would
say he lost the locker room but dude
there's no way that the [__] Raiders
are beating them 63 to 21 whatever the
[__] they did that was just like yeah
they quit that was yeah dude you saw the
guy's eyes now they're coming back Paul
you got to think this week you know now
they got to save their jobs they got
what they wanted they got rid of their
coach and how about the Buffalo Bills
Expo did they expose the Cowboys Paul is
it time to hit the panic button down
there in Dallas Texas you know it was
good for the bills when I saw Stefon
Diggs go up to Josh Allen and they gave
each other a because there was a little
thing there here's what I don't want to
hear from the Bills players what's that
you know all you guys all you guys
counted us out you know you guys all had
us all written off it's like yeah cuz
you were playing terrible football I
[__] hate when that happens yeah cuz
you sucked yes cuz you lost like seven
out of eight [__] games you shouldn't
have lost because you were so favored
yeah we were we were judging it on how
you were playing yeah um are you not
entertained if I see one more [__]
athlete doing that like he's in there
fighting lions it's the stupidest [__]
ever dude that's got to be the most
arrogant [__]
thing you could ever yell to a crowd
unless they killed your whole family and
you have to fight to the death with
people you know other the Gladiators
then you can say are you not entertained
you bloodthirsty pieces of [__] but I
don't want to watch you [__] throwing
a ball around yeah and then turn around
like like what do I have to do yeah like
my life is that [__] boring I'll
watch the NF I watched it before you
were in the league and I'll watch it
after and guess what I won't miss you
won't miss you um the only time an
athlete said are you not entertained
that I thought it was worthy of doing so
was when Michael Chandler in the UFC was
Bloody down to this and it was the thing
where they both let their guards down
and they were just smashing each other
in the face and not fighting like not
trying to hide it and he was just piled
with blood and the crowd's going nuts
and he just goes are you not entertained
I was like all right I kind of am
entertained I mean yeah I mean I don't
have a problem with that
[Laughter]
one yeah you sitting there on an air
conditioned bench or a heated seat you
know are you not entertained all right
let's [__] yeah you hit a three in
the first quter you know these are
things I can I can do without in sports
here's another thing too dunking on
nobody and then there's nobody under the
rim and you dunk and then you got to
go yeah I don't I don't like what
somebody like you're a [__] Marine
yeah I don't like when somebody hits a
three and they go like this after they
hit a three they
go they count it's so [__]
cringeworthy my favorite thing are the
DJs when people make fun of the DJs then
they just take what you just said and
they turned it into a song proving their
point that it's recyclable garbage music
it's like dude I said that [__]
yesterday you already have it you it's
the same [__]
oh here it [__] comes was the base
drop oh
[__] yo [__] I I was thinking about you
last night CU my Nicks were playing the
net also I don't like people that DJ at
a basketball game and act like they're
at the height of their [__] field
well that that's all right you're you're
like [__] two bad songs away from
going back to the Gap yeah that's why
that was my next point I'm watching the
Knicks play the Nets and I remember you
and I there and I swear to God Bill I'm
not exaggerating you could watch as soon
they tip the ball and the Nets won the
tip by the way the Knicks blew them out
by 20 uh as soon as the Nets tip the
ball the Nets get the they win the tip I
swear to God you just heard
Brooklyn and the whole place is chanting
it and dude there were so many Nick fans
that by the time we were up 20 the net
fans were upset with how many Nick fans
were in there they were complaining
about it's the best um all those Traders
all those rats that's a bunch of Henry
Hills that's the Henry Hill fan base oh
it's a [__] rat tra in there
um all
right what else any other good
storylines dude I just hate seeing all
these quarterbacks hurt man this is the
first year the NFL's had this many
backups but your boy Browning you know
Paul I had a stomach flu [__] two
weeks ago and no not one quarterback
starting or backup called up to see if I
was okay so I mean that's a part of the
game let's go who do you got all right
all
Paulie all right well
I am going to take with my first
pick it's a lot of lot of
[__] you're killing time here Paul
what's going on come on Paul you got the
Swagger you're killing the
book I'm gonna take Sneaky Pete and the
Seahawks minus two and a half against
Tennessee oh all right okay I like that
okay okay
um I don't know why I'm going to do this
but I'm I'm just going to do this this
is a stupid [__]
bet uh I'm going to take the bills I
think the bills need to keep this
momentum going they have to and I just
think the Chargers as much as they're
going to try to save their [__]
jobs um unless they all just agreed to
quit last week so they could get rid of
their coach even though it's in Los
Angeles I still don't feel like that's
their home uh I'm going to take the
bills laying 12 on the road Paul coming
out like a total jackass this week I'm
already down 12 nothing Paul the game
isn't even for four [__]
days um all right well no I mean you're
going against a team that's completely
in shambles against a team that is
flying right now so I like that pick I
would say the bills are flying they're
back I think they they're kind of doing
what they should have been doing
everybody needs to relax about the bills
they're all excited that they're finally
doing something you should have been
doing that all year yeah that Dalvin
Cook's brother kid's nice that kid James
Cook he was running the B what no no
good ball player good ball player oh
you're using some sort of like lingo on
me there yeah he's a nice fresh Paul
where I'm from nice means you're a nice
guy he's a nice fresh dope mint
kid remember
mint uh oh for a car oh it's [__]
I'm going to take the Jacksonville
Jaguars off of a loss they lost on prime
time they are playing the Buccaneers who
are playing
well but the Jags are the better team
the Jags need the win I'm gonna take
Jacksonville getting one point in Tampa
off of a bad loss on prime time you said
Jags one more time it was going to
become a drinking game um all right I am
uh G to go against my Ravens this week
and I'm going to take the 49ers at home
minus 4 and a half you know why Paul cuz
I'm a
Believer I bet against these [__]
guys enough times that Christian
mcaffrey what let me guess let me guess
Jake The Snake is he hurt this week is
that what it
is
no nope said gives me a no yeah he's not
hurt but Lawrence is hurt it's gonna
throw that out
there all right well Joey Lawrence I
don't think he plays football so I'm
going to go with the 4 ERS minus four
and a half minus four and a half Paul
I'm laying 16 and a half after two
picks oh [__] Trevor Lawrence is hurt
he's not playing he might play but
concussion so it's it's unclear but um
yeah he he probably
won't he's showing his toughness this
year Trevor Lawrence that guy is uh that
guy's the real
deal yeah he's great he really is um
about Brock py get getting all that love
finally this week all these [__]
like me saying that he was just driving
a Ferrari and they start breaking down
the field hey thring a ball before they
even make the break the level of skill
that takes and the trust in your
receiver I was like all right all right
people who know it more than I do said
that so I believe in it I hate this week
dude this is my least favorite week oh
Paul don't say that I hate it don't be
like
that ah you already wore your [__] Brown
hoodie the seven and I've never seen you
wear why you don't wear brown I like
brown man you do yeah I never seen Paul
come on Paul Paul you're you're [__]
Italian you dress the color of the
Angels he get you in a white on white
linen I mean Flo across that
room doesn't spill a drop of the red
wine man it's a [__] thing to see the
the Seven and Seven Saints are playing
the seven and seven Rams tonight I'm
going to the game oh well you know what
then I'm gonna do it just you may you
got me excited excited you know what I'm
not doing anything tonight Polly was
under the weather I'm going to watch the
game I'm going to take the Rams minus
four unless you were going to do that
because you're at the game then I'll
give that to you I was E I I I don't I
just don't the Rams are yeah I don't
know what the [__] they are and the
Saints too the Saints like every once in
a while they just [__] kick the [__]
out of somebody they're both erratic
Paul they're crazy chicks were you gonna
take the game crazy [__] [__] CH huh
were you gonna take the game because
you're going no okay I'm gonna take the
r being so courteous all right I'm gon
take Theus four there you go Matthew
Stafford Prime Time Rams first game
prime time I think let's go all right
I'm taking the New York football
Giants on the road getting 12 I know the
Eagles have been rumbling bumbling and
stumbling and [__] I think uh oh [__]
uh Tony rag goo goes down
there what is it Tommy cutlet goes down
there
I think he keeps him in there maybe
sequin Paul can do something for me not
fumble the ball or anything 12
points I don't know I I'm I'm starting
to think the Eagles are hurt or
something like there there's got to be
something going on with their offensive
line something's going on that's what
Kelsey was saying to his brother on the
podcast and he's the center he goes yeah
something's off with us I couldn't
believe he was saying that um yeah but
that's good that he says that he's
addressing it he's not afraid he's not
walking away I like
that all right I like that a lot for my
fourth and final pick I like how you
saying this like it's a trick and for my
fourth and final pick remember that uh
what's his I'll need a volunteer from
the dunan Kyle dunan go he goes like
this they always go like this all right
you see it you
see I haven't seen him do that he just
again is one of the funniest human
beings
ever um I'm gonna take the Chicago Bears
at home minus four they almost pulled
that Miracle Hail Mary on the road I
think yeah it's at Bears against the
Cardinals who've shown nothing I'm gonna
take Chicago to pull out to to win that
game all right
um um I don't like any of this you know
what Paul why the [__] are the Packers
only four and a half over the Panthers
because they won last week
uh you know what I I I hear Whispering I
just heard some Whispering somebody's
talking I guess I'm doing a bad job here
you know what I'm gonna go was that you
Paul yeah Paul you're out there
Whispering this time of
year Paulie who loves Christmas he's
sitting there talking to himself I I I
can't believe it all right I like the
Packers I like their
quarterback
um that's a good and I just think
profession Sports in the state of
Carolina are
cursed I just don't think that um you
know Kobe was
drafted by the [__] what are they
called The Crickets what the hell were
they the Hornets and he's just like yeah
I'm not playing for you guys the NBA was
like all right so right there they just
said to all the fans of the Hornets
which then became the [__] whatevers
down there in New Orleans and then they
got the Bobcats they're basically saying
you guys are never going to be good the
that's the NBA product um so they got
that going on and then the Panthers I
mean both of them just play in these
[__] stadiums I think it just
affects
yeah um well I need to I may have to do
a change
here uh if Trevor Lawrence is not
playing I don't like the Jaguars in that
game so dude when did you become such a
[__] Karen can we can we find out can
we find out you use some young person
slang earlier so I wanted to do it
too I like that guy that guy's nice oh
did you meet him no I mean he's a good
player
oh um if we could find out if Trevor
Lawrence is playing I'd like to know
that if not I'm Gonna Change why don't
you text him Paul you're selling out
clubs Ben big shot over there
I'm what is concussion concussion
protocol what does concussion protocol
even mean they don't know now I love
saying this year it's they're saying
this year it's the most lenient
concussion protocol in the past few
years look at your eyes look at your
eyes he's good he's fine let go you got
gets upset his head goes I mean what
what what is that even
mean he puffs up a little Paul you get a
little bigger you know you you're trying
to get you're trying to get some [__]
answers I'll keep the Jags I'll keep the
Jags you know what I'll keep don't let
me talk you into it Paul I am [__]
poisoned this year no I don't don't know
I don't know I don't like any other game
what are you gonna take don't you though
but don't you know I mean the commanders
and jets I'd rather I like that game I
like that game I like that game no
why cause Anything Can Happen Falcons
Colts I mean what I mean this week might
be the worst well Falcons and coats
that's [__] if anybody can pick that
game I just you know I don't want to see
your personal
life if if Trevor Lawrence isn't playing
I'll will take the Cowboys so I need to
know I need to
know it just says he's still you're me
way why can't we just let [__] Paul
wait why can't we just let him wait and
if he's [__] playing here's the deal
if the guy's playing he has the [__]
Jaguars if he's not then he's got the
the Cowboys right you know what I'll
change
it oh dude do I like the Dolphins nah
you know what I'm keeping the Jaguars
plus one whether it's Trevor Lawrence or
not I'm GNA take the better I'm going to
take the Jaguars keep my pick no
changes okay I saw it I liked it and
then I'd kick myself if it went it the
other way let's just keep hey Paul you
can sleep with your
pics hey maybe not that one
okay uh wow man all right so there you
go now bill you know oh bill it's time
for your Monday night special and it's
the Ravens and 49ers and you had already
picked the 49ers I like the 49ers
because the 49ers are going to say [__]
them they think they're going to the
Super Bowl against us we'll show them
what we'll do to them in the Super Bowl
I say we pile on the Vengeance game the
Ravens beat the 49ers in the Super Bowl
about 10 or 11 years ago yep well
Christian mcaffry for a touchdown I
called that by the way you can go on my
Twitter the the morning of the Super
Bowl I said take the
Ravens it's the last time I called the
game correctly Paul it's been an 11year
[__]
drought all right well Christian
McCaffrey to get one no I mean that's a
done deal yeah Jesus loves him that kid
gets a touch name Christian yeah you
know he just has that Utah energy
right like Clorox
White
he just yeah he really do went to
America he should have went to BYU with
the way he looks yeah it's just
like like he's Acappella group
white that's oh my god dude I was in the
dental office the other day and this
acapella [__] version of Rudolph the
Red-nosed Ranger came Ranger reindeer
came on it was so bad I had to Shazam it
and start sending it to people like are
they
mocking oh man that's funny are they
mocking Acappella groups like The
Arrangement dude the arrangement was
like from
1958 Rudolph the red you know I said
that reindeer he's
coming down the chimney
tonight I was sitting there [__]
real oh oh [__]
um all right so we got the 49ers
mcaffrey you picked the you picked the
last
one oh 49ers mcaffrey and uh what's
what's uh what's the over under so we
can lose what is
it what's the
under my guess is good defenses well
look at that look at that Paul
yeah but dude you got Jamal what's his
name Jamar Jackson Lamar
Jackson you can te you can tease that up
till like if you want to take the en you
tease it up till 52 53 if you want still
get you know odds so whatever you want
to do with that number I would tease
that
up tease it up take the
under okay phone a friend tease it can
you tease it to what though Andrew
we said it he just said it Paul whatever
yeah just your odds go down Paul well no
go down and take the over whatever you
want to do I don't know what I'm talking
about the most you could tease is six
you can't just tease whatever well no I
know but I mean you know I'm saying
you're not gonna go to 53 you know it's
the holidays let's not fight okay all
right so let's go to you so we'll go to
53 and take it
down hey Paul what what whatever you
want whatever makes you happy hey we
make the rules we make the rules no Paul
I'm doing a little holiday sarcasm
passive
aggressiveness no hey you know whatever
makes you happy no listen whatever you
want to eat I'll get you tell me you
know those people no I'll go to theore
whatever you want you know be great to
punch somebody in the face through a
wreath you know so you add like a
holiday flare to it like just some
relative you've always wanted to punch
in the face what you do is you go can
you be F you just hold that up like that
and they just came him a [__]
straight
[Laughter]
right and then and then through the
wreath through the wreath you do what's
his face from from uh uh Casino hey
smarten up then you just [__] walk
away Oh I thought you were going to say
the guy Frank Vincent the guy in Atlanta
who had his head in the box and he went
Bo oh my god dude that guy was amazing
no he didn't close it he went like he
went like that it slammed shut in his
face um yeah I'm talking about you know
I'm talking about these people you know
what people drive me crazy that they go
I'm gonna do this a bit about this where
they go I'm hangry I'm sorry I'm hangry
I'm just hungry and it's like you know
who else is hungry like I'm hungry too I
don't I'm not going to take it out on
you [__] eat a snack that's all
there's all there's all kinds of excuses
out there Paul yeah my blood sugar I'm
sorry [__] go eat a [__] Apple eat
something I'm hungry too and you know
what it is Paul it's always been that
way oh Paul how about [__] Nick
Sabin how about Nick Sabin you know he's
going up against those cheating Michigan
Wolverines who are stealing signs you
know what this [__] guy did what he
hired one their ex linebacker coach in
21 and 22 for one month preparation to
play Michigan and that's that's oh
that's fine there's no nothing in the
rule book against that this guy knows
their whole [__]
Playbook wow yeah but stealing signs
Paul I mean you could go up in front of
the [__] Senate if they catch you
trying to figure out what's going
on unreal yep
unreal yeah it's it's
it's so ridiculous how people like you
can't root for them anymore look what
happened with them look what happened
with them never I know and I'm goingon
to say something then all these BigTime
coaches are always talking about
integrity and raising men and [__]
doing it right G gag G they're doing the
same [__] any [__] Corporation would
be doing sabin's been giving recruits
Ferraris from his car dealership for
decades too and nobody cares oh Jake The
Snake he has a Ferrari dealership all
right now I like him to liking Nick
sa yeah I'll be honest I'm playing for
Alabama I'll tell you this it takes a
lot of balls to be the head coach of
Alabama and sell foreign cars in that
[__]
State I'll tell you right now Ferrari
ain't nothing but a [__] souped up
Toyota goddamn ferrar's get that
Japanese [__] out of my State uh it's
Italian same
difference
they're both
disgusting um all right they're both
less than me on the Jesus
ladder uh all right there you go I gotta
go I feel I'm starting I'm starting not
you you're on the bench because I'm
ha I like that southern accent down
there when they they had the H they
pronounced the H in white white gold
genuine white
gold ah dude one of my favorite guys
from Alabama is the sound guy at Brad
Garretts the sound guy at Brad Garretts
Andre he's the best dude he would Gamble
and he would uh he was the guy I said he
was the he said he was the guy who would
make a point and then agree with himself
he go I'll tell you why man he goes I
tell you why because he goes they don't
have a defense and their running game is
suspect uh huh that's
right I was like I'm not even arguing
with you Andre that that's my favorite
guy from Alabama that's like subliminal
man oh dude Mets tickets Mets tickets
um all right Paul let's wrap this up yes
there you go everybody those are our
picks that's the Monday night special
let's get under 53 let's get mcaffrey in
the end zone let's get 49ers to win the
game by five let's get the [__] out of
here $10 in your B MGM account use our
code bonus code uh Burr b r put in $10
and if the BET loses you will get up to
$1,500 in bonus bets bet responsibly
everybody we will see you next week on
week 17 I always like the
Yankees see next soulless look on her
face brand new Yankee hat it's like your
husband's been in office for eight years
they've won four World Series and you
I've never seen you at any of the
celebrations no
never um I agree I enjoyed her campaign
failing as much as I've enjoyed the
Eagles losing three weeks in a
[Laughter]
row I don't even hate the Eagles I just
love their coach and I know he's
emotional so I either want them to be
like winning a bunch or losing a bunch I
want to see the guy on the [__]
opposite end of this either just like
talking [__] or freaking out Nick serani
has been quiet the last three weeks
that's for sure oh he's been looking up
at that scoreboard a lot and way too of
he's listening to Dark Side of the Moon
he's slipping into the madness they need
to [__] win this
week how funny is it when an NFL coach
is losing and they just do this the
clock look oh dude looking up at the
clock oh it's one of the worst jobs ever
it is it's I mean it's right after there
was stand up when you're having a bad
day at the office just you just
everybody's sitting there just watching
you you except you got the you suck oh
dude they get divorced the Dolphins
coach was like yeah I'm trying to spend
time with my daughter you know I try to
balance it dude they're in there like 17
hours a day
and then yeah you're not balancing
anything if you're a if you're a
coach no and I don't have the
temperament to have a reporter talk [__]
about me I'm Sicilian Bill if I see that
and I'm in the press conference I be
like who who really you said that I
don't know why they don't do that more
often oh that would be great hold him
responsible and then just fat shame him
that's what I would do I would just go
[__] schoolyard you just you just see
an NFL head coach fighting Sal pal
Antonio in theu well may if our
offensive line as much as your [__]
man titss we could get the running game
going what's your
question I'll take the fine yeah I'll
have a negative
salary um all right let's I gotta get on
with my day here Paulie all right buddy
I love you Paul good luck with your
Thursday night bet tonight oh oh have
fun at the game oh I will I'll bring my
earplugs I'll see you there I mean I'll
see you
later bye
bye